as we enter into the 6th century bce the
dominant power in the region that we now
refer to as iran it was the median
empire and the median empire i'll draw
the rough border
right over here well something
was something
like that and you can see the dominant
region of media right over here but by
the middle of that century they're going
to be overthrown and they're going to be
overthrown by one of their subject
kingdoms and that that is the persians
and so right over here on this map it's
called persis but that region is called
pars or fars and even today in modern
iran that region is called fars and the
king of pars was cyrus the great
and in 550 549 bce he's able to
overthrow the median emperor who happens
to be his grandfather and then he
establishes what history views as the
first
real persian empire and the whole reason
why we even call it a persian empire is
because cyrus the great was from pars
persian is really referring to the idea
that the the ruler the dynasty that gets
established was coming from pars it
turns out and i talk about in other
videos the persians did not you did not
refer to themselves as persians they
view themselves more as the aryan people
in a lot of ways iran or iran or aryanum
of asia and these these types of words
are more accurate for how the persians
viewed themselves but needless to say in
549 cyrus the great is able to conquer
the median empire and he keeps going and
what he establishes this this empire
this dynasty is called the achaemenid
dynasty
khimanid
and you might wonder why is it called
the khimidi dynasty instead of say the
siren dynasty and that's because cyrus
claims descendant from echemonies
he is part of that family
a chemise is this semi-legendary a
patriarch of it that lived 150 years
before cyrus the great and so i will
draw a dotted line for dotted line from
achievements
to cyrus and cyrus then goes on so he
conquers
the median empire then he goes on to
conquer several of the major empires of
that time in the mid 540s bce
so we are right around there he conquers
the libyan empire
right over there which is on the western
half of the anatolian peninsula in
modern day turkey and then he sets his
sight on the neo-babylonian empire and
in 539 he's able to conquer the
neo-babylonian empire and from a
biblical perspective that's relevant
because when he takes babylon he frees
the jews from the babylonian captive
captivity and he resettles them in
jerusalem and he works with them to
rebuild the city of jerusalem and
especially solomon's temple which is now
called the second temple on the temple
mount and cyrus the great is viewed by
history as one of the great rulers of
all time often referred to as a model
ruler someone who really takes the
interest of his people at heart
so cyrus was able to conquer a lot of
what you see here in green but not all
of it and especially he was not able to
get to egypt that would be left to his
son canvases so in 5 30 cyrus dies
and canvases takes over and just so you
read what's with this how i made this
timeline and i made this timeline really
to help myself understand the various
sha and shahs or king of kings of iran
so cyrus the great was the shah and shah
king of kings and then camber sees the
second was the next one is that this
timeline up here this shows who is in
charge so you see from 5
50 549 all the way to 5 30 i have it
yellow and that's because cyrus the
great was in charge of what is called
the accumulated empire or this i guess
you say this first great persian empire
what i have down here is at the best
information i could find on the life
spans of these people and when i have
these dotted lines at the beginning
that's when it's unclear when these
people were born so there's different
accounts that cyrus the great might have
been born in 575 bce he might have been
born closer to
600 bce and so that's why i have these
dotted lines similarly we don't know
exactly when canvases the second was
born but we knew we do know that he took
control in 530 bce and so that's why you
see canvases
you see this line right over here turn
blue and actually canvases ends up dying
in 522. so let me actually
this should be like that there you go he
ends up dying at 522 but before he dies
in 522 he is able to conquer egypt in
525
bce so right around there
and you can imagine that while he's
conquering egypt let me keep drawing
this family tree so now we have canvases
canvases
canvases the second he goes off makes
his real goal to conquer
egypt and that's a big deal remember
this is ending thousands of years of the
rule by the native pharaohs they start
the the these now foreign rulers start
calling themselves the pharaohs of egypt
as well but they get they they get put
in to egypt becomes part of the persian
empire because of canvases but you can
imagine with the shah and shah with the
king of kings often doing conquest in
egypt it leaves a little power vacuum
back in the center of the empire
and this is when things get a little bit
sketchy
so
the cyrus does have another son the
other son is called bardia
so let me write this down so there is
another son
called bardia and then there's this
other character known as darius soon to
be known as darius the great
and darius is not a direct descendant of
cyrus the great but he is part of his
family he's a distant relative he is
part of the achaemenid dynasty a part of
he claims descendant from akeeminese and
he was the lance bearer for campuses the
second
so while canbacis is out here in egypt
leaving that power vacuum someone who
claims to be bartia takes
someone who claims to be bartia takes
control of the empire or is trying to
take control of the empire
now some accounts say that this is
really bartia this is really the other
son of cyrus the great and so there
would be some legitimate claim to the
throne but there's other claims
especially the ones that darius
was later able to uh spread that no this
was not the real party that this was a
fake party that the real party had
actually been killed by canvases the
second before and that this person
proposing to be barty it was this fake
usurper this zoroastrian priest named
gamada
and
once kanbacy is on his way he's trying
to come back in order to reclaim the
throne or in order to
get rid of this usurper whether it was
the real party or not but on the way he
dies and once again it's under dubious
circumstances cyrus the great how he
died not clear candice's ii also dies
under dubious circumstances and then
this bartia is actually becomes the shah
and shah for real he's obviously
has claims to it while kamesis is there
but once cabinet sees dies he is the
shan shah well darius doesn't like this
he has his own
imperial ambitions he gets some other
nobility together and says no no this
this barty isn't the real bardia he's a
usurper uh let's go kill that guy and so
they kill him and then it's an
interesting story uh herodotus has a
fairly dubious account of of how
darius was able to convince the other
noble people why why he should be the
shan shah the emperor but they are able
to get rid of bartia we still do not
know whether it was the real bardia or
whether it was the fake bardia but then
darius takes power in 522
bce
and he's known as darius the great
because he continues to spread he
continues to conquer more and more uh
for the persian empire and this map
right over here this is the persian
empire in 500 bce under darius the great
it's near the its maximum extent and
it's a pretty incredible empire it's
worth noting it's big by any stretch of
the imagination
but it's at this time the population is
on the order of 50 million people and
based on the accounts that i've seen
that's almost half of the world
population at that time no empire in
history as far as we can tell has ever
had such a large fraction of the world's
population under its control and so that
gives you a sense of i guess you could
say how great or how large an empire
this was
now darius the great he is also famous
especially from a greek perspective for
going after the greeks you had you had
these greek revolts in these in these
towns on the west coast of of the
anatolian peninsula they revolted
against their persian overlords i guess
you could say and they did that with the
help of the athenians and so darius
didn't like this in the uh in the 490s
he starts going after the athenians this
is the beginning of the greco-persian
wars he is unsuccessful he dies in the
480s and then his son this is actually a
relief of darius the great right over
here from persepolis and then his son
tri continues to try to take over in the
second
greco-persian wars and he too is
unsuccessful but it's worth noting a lot
of this history that we get especially
of cyrus the great and the early uh
persian shan shaws the history we get is
from the greeks so it's worth taking it
with a grain of salt because as you can
see they were rivals and to say rivals
is a little bit unfair to the persians
because the greeks were more of a third
in the south thorn in the side of a
large empire the greeks were this
group of
city-states they weren't even a unified
empire while you had here the persian
empire controls almost half of the
world's population so the greeks were
more of a third floor on the side but we
we get our history from them or a lot of
our history from them so uh we we get
their account of things
now once as you have xerxes then after
xerxes you have arda cersei's right he
over here and then you have a little bit
of a squabble for the throne and then
darius the second there's one thing that
you see over the over 200 years of a
keeminid rule is that most people after
darius the great are known are named
either xerxes artaxerxes darius the
second third fourth our uh or darius the
second or third at least uh not fourth
uh arda cersei's uh artist versus second
artist issues third so it gets a little
confusing but the reason why i even did
this for myself to see when all of these
people lived and when they ruled is to
have a good sense of of what was going
on and
and how darius ii how lived at a
different time than for example darius
the first or darius the great the other
thing worth mentioning because you'll
hear this in various history classes
when you talk about the persian empire
is the the great cities of the persian
empire cyrus the great he establishes
the capital at passage right over here
you have canvases establishes a capital
at susa susa is one end of the great
royal highway that goes from sardis all
the way
to susa right over there you have darius
the great establish a capital at
persepolis and this and that's the greek
name for it literally referring to
persian city and this is a relief from
persepolis right over here now the end
of the achievement dynasty comes when
that famous thorn in the side greece
actually unifies under philip of macedon
and here we're talking about the earl
the mid to the mid to or early to mid
4th century bce and his son alexander
becomes this great conqueror alexander
the great and he's able to conquer the
entire persian empire famously taking it
away from darius iii we talk about that
in another video or in several videos in
some detail but alexander the great he
has this vision of a of us of a one
nation of these people uh kind of their
culture is mixing together and there's a
significant amount of cultural mix
between the greeks and the persians but
then alexander dies and his empire split
but the the most of the persian empire
goes to uh under the control of
celicas who's one of alexander's
generals and then you have the seleucid
empire which is really foreign rule of
persia and that will continue for a
while until eventually the parthians
which is once again another
state or region of the persian empire
takes control to establish the parthian
empire which is one of the rivals to
rome that's worth mentioning and i
mentioned this in the video on ancient
persia that under persian rule and cyrus
and the various shan shasta are famous
for delegating their authority when you
have such a large empire you can't
control all of it yourself so each of
these regions had their own i guess you
could say governors and those governors
were called satraps and the regions were
called the trapeze anyway i will leave
you there oh the other thing that cyrus
the great is really known for is the
spread of the zoroastrian faith we talk
about the zoroastrian faith in other
videos
and
zarathustra who is the kind of the
prophet of the zoroastrian faith he
lived someplace between 1500 bce and
might have even lived
shortly right before almost near the
time of science the great but it was
really seis the great who helps spread
this great ancient faith